put your fake baby in a spacesuit and
drug your nanny with a pizza because we
have season 2 of servant and if you
haven't seen the show
holy crap it's giving me total lost
vibes speaking of which if you add up
all the numbers someone has to enter in
the hatch
they equal 108 the address for the
ritual building found in the final
episode but we're going to get into that
and a ton
of insane theories including who that
dead body was between the wall
is julian really julian and maybe i'll
even throw in a recipe for my cheese's
crust pizza but before we begin
make sure to like the video subscribe
and comment below with your thoughts and
theories
the final episode of servant season 2 is
called josephine named after the
mysterious visitor the turner family
receives who may hold the key to
bringing their son
jericho back josephine is a hebrew name
meaning god
raises and with how this show deals with
resurrection it's no wonder why they
chose this name
as an aside i like how they chose
dorothy as a name for actress laura
ambrose's character
and not to dorothy in the wizard of oz
who lives in a fantasy world just like
our dorothy lives in a fantasy world
believing her child is still alive
leanne holds the fake baby jericho
watching as aunt josephine arrives it's
not her
real aunt members of the church of the
lesser saints call each other by names
like
aunt uncle and cousin as we'll see with
the guy in the betamax video who refers
to himself as
uncle frederick speaking of the betamax
that's what josephine brings so that
leanne can watch the video that arrived
earlier that day betamax was invented in
1975
so the video we do see later on could be
anytime in the 70s or 80s but i'll get
to that in a bit we'll notice that aunt
josephine wears gloves and a black
veil almost as if she's getting dressed
for a funeral and that might be
appropriate since she attempts to kill
leanne for straying from the path of the
church of lesser saints the veil and
gloves also have an added purpose of
covering her
burn marks there are two theories out
there on where these marks came from
one she could be a survivor from the
church of lesser saints cult fire that
occurred
years ago or two she's leanne's mother
who survived the fire that burned down
their house
i don't happen to believe this second
one since we'd probably get a different
reaction from leanne if that were the
case
plus i personally don't think she looks
like the photo that julian found and it
was reported that charred remains were
found in that fire and when leanne talks
to sean she says she doesn't know who
she is
but wants to know her name and the burn
marks could be from something totally
unrelated
and just a plot device to show that even
the most devout of the church members
can give into sins like a vanity vanity
is a sin
and josephine josephine asked to see
dorothy who she calls a warrior for
having to go through all this suffering
but dorothy won't let her see lynn until
jericho is safely back in her arms
dorothy will do anything for her child
including giving up leanne it's jericho
for the end this will be important later
on since leanne believes dorothy
truly loves her josephine inquires as to
what leanne wants
i want to stay here with the turners
which josephine says isn't an option the
turners
don't love her something leanne believes
to be untrue
we also get a shot of dorothy praying
over the fake baby
this is extremely odd since we've seen
her throughout the season denounce god
and superstition well that's good
because we no longer allow superstition
in this house
but i guess when you're desperate you'll
do anything and dorothy is desperate
even willing to kill herself to be with
her dead son
josephine gives dorothy a baby onesie
with this little piggy stitched onto it
a nod to the grim nursery rhyme about
pigs being sent to the market for
slaughter
she asks what is this
it's the truth hinting that her son is
dead
which technically is true her son died
before the events
of season 1. sean calls julian his go-to
guy when [ __ ] hits the fan he's not
picking up
probably because he died last episode
after odin only to be resuscitated by
lyanne now there is a theory out there
that this resurrection of sorts resulted
in the soul of sergio the little boy who
leanne took care of
and was murdered by his father being put
in julian's body
i don't really believe this since when
he's brought back he acts like this same
old julian
but he says this cryptic line to leanne
i saw him there
he seemed okay i think he saw sergio
which by the way the name sergio means
servant and he wanted to let leanne know
that as dorothy inspects the baby outfit
sean checks in on her but gets locked in
his room and
out of his phone why does his password
no longer work why does the door
lock on him i think this is most likely
leanne or josephine's work here
later we'll see when leanne prays the
door unlocks on sean there's also this
question of whether the turner family is
or will be under some sort of spell
where they forget things
and i'll get into that in a bit there's
also the possibility that the house
itself can morph and take on
supernatural elements there have been
references in the past that the house
has a history
something season 3 could delve into
josephine brings george's wooden box
that we saw in episodes 7 and 8 to
leanne who has prepared the video
this box is filled with oils a knife and
a lighter and these oils are what
josephine will later use to blind leanne
as part of the four steps
and the four steps are what we learn in
the betamax video featuring uncle
frederick who gives us a traditional
baphomet greeting
with his two fingers pointing up and
thumb out baphomet has become this
occult
symbol initially the templars were
accused of worshiping it but recently
it's been used as a symbol by the
satanic temple you'll notice some cool
things here like these banker boxes
these two are easy to read barbara's
medicine and the years
73 74. the ones here are much harder but
this is what i see new applicant
paperwork noelle's editorial steven's
constitution
alfred's garden and raquel's women's
wear this video is a guide to perform a
reunion ritual or how to return
lost members back to life the ritual is
done in
four steps step one is invocation where
one listens to music to remind them of a
time
something good happened and you
self-mutilate yourself you'll see a
large wooden cross here in the
background the same kind we've seen
leanne create
throughout the two seasons the herding
of the flesh is supposed to separate
themselves from these false
feelings of happiness step two is
consecration where the soul is separated
from the body
this involves blinding the subject and
cutting their limbs so the soul can be
released from the body to be reunited
with god
after the scene we cut to dorothy
hearing the cries of her baby who
clearly isn't there but during this cut
and let me know if i'm wrong here
we don't get to see a step 3 when we
return back
to the video frederick tells us we're
ready for the final step
emancipation i feel the only reason they
wouldn't show us this step is that it
gives away something they're saving for
season three
something that would give away too much
at this point in the story
emancipation involves burning the body
in a handmade pyre this was something
george was preparing a few episodes ago
my own theory is that this third step
involves a ritual in preparing the body
for that burning this could have
something to do with transference of
souls
frederick says these steps must be done
quickly and in order to work
keep that in mind as we go along rituals
are done when one of the members goes
quote unquote bad and it's done as a
preemptive strike so that further
innocent men and women are saved
remember that leanne was tasked with
looking over the mourinho family the
family that eventually was killed by its
crazed father leanne was supposed to be
there that night maybe she was meant to
die
too but by coming back it has altered
god or someone else's
will josephine here is sent to right
that wrong the betamax video after all
is said to be a quote final warning i
take it to be a scare tactic of what
will happen if leanne doesn't follow
what josephine says
and josephine asks her to renounce
dorothy but leanne won't say it and when
this happens
josephine knows she can't be saved and
thus the ritual must be performed on her
she sprays acid in her face
blinding her which is actually step two
of the ritual then we see her stabbing
herself with a fork while listening to
music step one already josephine is
performing these
out of order around this time the door
holding shawn back is mysteriously
unlocked
notice how the window is open here in
the middle of winter it's
really odd combine this with sean later
being found outside near the greenhouse
when dorothy is looking for him
something doesn't quite add up what's
compelling him to be there
sean talks to dorothy who is on the
verge of suicide she has this feeling
that
jericho is gone but shawn is able to
talk her out of it where she eventually
saves leanne from josephine who
continues her assault
dorothy saving lyanne confirms leanne's
belief that
dorothy truly cares for her see
she protected me i come her daughter
leanne has so yearned for a mother
figure in her life considering her
own mother was so cruel to her but the
odd thing here is that dorothy has been
insanely cruel to leanne too drugging
her keeping her captive in the attic
and beating her every night at 2am it's
like some weird stockholm syndrome
[ __ ] is really going to hit the fan when
leanne realizes dorothy will
sell her out in a heartbeat if it means
getting jericho back
i also found it weird that dorothy
leaves leanne alone in the basement with
this killer to go find sean
whether this is some sort of mystery or
the writers needed a reason to get
leanne alone with josephine is not known
but something about this whole thing is
fishy sean and dorothy have a heart to
heart with him almost on the verge of
telling her that jericho is dead the
real jericho died as an infant causing
dorothy to go into this hysteria where
she believed the
fake doll was real but before he goes
through with it the baby monitor pops on
and we hear leanne singing row row row
your boat the couple goes into the
nursery to find her there with a baby
and i happen to believe this is the real
jericho resurrected judging by sean's
reaction when he sees the baby
he recognizes it as being jericho notice
here that leanne is wearing a coat she
was
obviously outside doing something maybe
in that greenhouse where shawn was
earlier but here's the big question
how did leanne have enough time to
perform all the steps of the ritual
and move this dead body into the side of
the wall let's go over
what we know leanne stabbed joe in the
eye sean finds the gramophone having
finished an entire record we see a body
within the walls of the house next to
leanne's room the first theory is that
this body is
josephine's but if it is it raises the
question how did she get it up there and
into the wall this could only be done if
a the turners were under some sort of
spell or hypnosis by leanne
b time works differently in this house
or c
the body isn't josephine's at all now
there are some theories that this body
is
julian's and this largely stems from
what people believe to be a ring on the
finger we know julian wears a ring but i
think it's inconclusive that's a ring at
all and julian didn't wear one on his
left middle finger
also leanne's final speech is spoken out
loud as if it's to this dead body
saying that she knows this death would
start a war if it were julian how would
that start a war killing josephine would
definitely have that implication so
right now i put my bet on josephine
there even seems to be some sort of
bible beside her but it could also be a
completely different body altogether the
season ends with lien saying she feels
the dark thing in her getting bigger
there's a theory out there that she is
the daughter of two evil people thus she
is evil herself
the church raised her and tried to make
her good but it's not in her nature
as dorothy says in episode three
sometimes in life
we have to just put our feet up and
accept that nature knows best
the last thing i want to discuss which i
found interesting but i didn't quite
know where to put it in the video is the
mysterious person
roscoe refers to while hypnotized he
says
that on their knees for him
he takes out the eyes and he throws them
away
his hand is a hook this hook hand thing
makes me think of captain hook and peter
pan which is even weirder when you see
that dorothy does a story with the words
fly like peter pan in episode 4. i'm
wondering if this person is the big bad
guy we haven't met yet there are still
many unanswered questions and i want to
hear what you thought of the season and
your theories in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone make sure
to like and subscribe and share this
with your fellow servant fans
you can also follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much